that camera take him that camera hello
I'm Darrell Johnson and today we will be
talking about the act
[Laughter]
hello I'm Darrell Johnson and today we
will be talking about the occupation
about the traders cheers my friend
so there was a big fire that happened in
1969 and it burned down the American
Indian Center in San Cisco so there's a
group of people called the Indians of
all tribes and they were like man we
gotta find a new place to gather we got
to be somewhere where we can be
ourselves so there was these three
leaders okay Richard Oakes Lunada means
and Adam fortunate eagle and they were
like faith in this red according to the
Treaty of Fort Lamy in 1868 it says the
Native Americans are allowed to
confiscate abandoned federal land for
their own use
now the same Alcatraz prison fence
sitting there empty the six years as
federal surplus land so oh yeah we got
our new location and the right and they
were like well let's just take
so on November 20th 1969 the coalition
alike 89 members of the Indians of all
trials cruise across the sampson still
bay and some fat-cat land tycoon was
over there like hey man I got these
plans they developed this in a module
monte carlo themed casino like maybe he
wouldíve dumbass play it's baby you
stole it from us once but we're gonna
steal it from your ass man I mean
started spray-painting stuff on the
walls like welcome to Indian land and
like red power
I like that one and then Adam fortunate
ego I'm still on the mainland because he
was the spokesperson for the tribe he
was like look ya'll we taking this
over okay y'all I ain't using it and we
need it all this belong to us anyway
okay and he said look we're not just
gonna take it out right we're not
terrible people
we'll give you $24 and glass beads and
some red cloth how about that and you
know why they gave me what I was glad
because that's how much the Dutch
merchants paid the Native Americans from
Manhattan now out someone who loves the
person who keeps their petty gamer but
that petty level is on a thousand and
all this information gives out more and
more people show up on Hanah and by
Thanksgiving Day in 1969 all hundred
people and now occupying Alcatraz how
ironic event Thanksgiving so of the 50
people there representing Alcatraz 40 of
them are women you're not a means like
you know why because they got a voice
and we recognize that look
we got a clinic running we got a kitchen
we got John Trudeau
The Voice the radio free Alcatraz and he
be like if you a Native American you can
come up here and be free and be yourself
and celebrate your own culture your
pride she's like we have set up a school
these kids are not learning from these
white man's history books they learning
about their history
we did that okay they may put middle
fingers all up in the government Richard
Nixon like oh bitch what's going on man
my man don't like losing something that
they stole anyway Richard Nixon was like
we can't attack these Native American
peoples we've got so much going on with
this country we have the Civil War no
not to Civil War civil right we can't
have another situation that's just
tricky date trying to save himself you
know he was already involved in the
scandal and stuff was about to go down
with him that he didn't even know about
yet but I do because this is drunk
history all that's history and I knew it
before he knew it no I'm saying that's
the target and so the Coast Guard like
yo okay which Nixon said we can't go in
there show no fourth great alright this
will become do we gonna take all day
fresher
we're gonna take the electrics thank you
let me say that right they take their
electricity and they set a fire I mean
they don't know who set the fire we put
my bets on it I feel it okay so in July
of 1971 the Cubs Karl atheist it was
like okay Native American peoples or
whatever you call yourself this lawn
balloons this land belongs to us white
man and the was over after the
almost two years Accu patien of Alcatraz
the fat cat was like hey man look I
don't think I want to build here no more
so the government turned it into a
national park and you can go there today
and still see some of the graffiti on
the walls
the Native Americans still come back
twice a year to celebrate the occupation
on what they now call on Thanksgivings
day
Christopher Columbus Day
that we now call indigenous peoples day
indigenous peoples day y'all indigenous
peoples day it's like we took this
y'all almost two years what did you do
today
check your mail hey some jello laughter
as you know
[Music]
you